hey everyone this is feed a master
Costilla Kavinsky here four chests calm
and today I'm going to be showing you
guys a really awesome game played by the
great champion Garry Kasparov this bar
over here is playing black and his
opponent was manga Rama who was another
strong player
so Kasparov was always famous for his
fantastic sense of the initiative in his
ability to always maximize the power of
his pieces and this game is one of the
earliest examples of this and I think
it's really instructive in regards to
how to play with the initiative and how
to continue the attack with a great
speed so I'm not going to go over the
opening too much because it's not really
important to the lecture but I hope you
know that this is the Queens gambit
declined and now white takes here on f6
gives up his dark squared Bishop so that
he can take on d5 and after black
recaptures he's left with this somewhat
passive Bishop on b7 that's shooting
into his own pawn on d5 so now white
played rook d1 and this move is designed
to discourage black from playing one of
his main ideas in this opening which is
c5 the reason black wants to play this
move is that he can open up the position
a bit for his two bishops in particular
his strong dark squared bishop which is
unopposed and now cuz far over here just
plays c5 anyways D takes e5 but I can't
recapture because his bishop would be
hanging but he can play the move Knight
d7 and the point is that if white
continues to take pawns black is going
to get a very nice lead development and
if we reach a position like this
although white is up a pawn he really
has no advantage here because by the
time white
gets his bishop out and castles black is
going to be able to play some rook to c8
and eventually build up pressure against
this knight on c3 along the C file in
this diagonal so in this case white
would not really have much of an
advantage here and black would win back
one of these pawns on the Queen side
pretty soon and equalize the game so in
this position white played a somewhat
more ambitious move c6 and this is just
to gain a little bit of time so he can
complete his development here Lefter
Bishop takes c6 Knight d4 Knight takes
d5 could have been played but after
Knight c59 f6 Queen f6 white would
probably want to trade Queens because
he's behind the development and we might
get a position like this where after
rook c8 black is down a pawn but he's
probably going to win back one of these
weak Queen side pawns here and after the
material is equalized neither side will
really have much of an advantage and
things will be about equal so this move
94 here is again a more ambitious way to
continue and Kasparov found here a very
good way to sort of punish white for his
optimistic play so in this position is
very important that you continue
actively you don't allow the other
player to finish their development and
consolidate their position and Kasparov
here found the move Bishop takes d4
which is surprisingly I think a
difficult move to find because
intuitively you don't want to give up
your dark squared bishop but his point
is concrete after the recapture e takes
d4 he's going to play Queen g5 and again
White has problems developing here
because of this pawn on g2 so g3 then
rook e8 check
and even queen g4 and I think black
definitely has the better position here
why can't castle because this Bishop on
e2 will be hanging and in the meantime
black is just going to play Queen h3
preventing white from castling and
double his rooks on the e-file bring his
knight in to f6 reroute this bishop
maybe to be seven and a six and with the
advantage in development I think black
is going to be doing really well so rook
takes d4 was played now Knight c5 Queen
d1 and night II 6 rook d2 and now a
really powerful move continuing the
initiative continuing the attack not
giving Y time to play Bishop e2 and
Castle because bar over here played d4
after white takes he played rook e8 so
this move d4 had two ideas the first was
to open up this long diagonal and add
pressure to g2 which hinders White's
development because once this bishop
leaves black will take the pawn on g2
and white won't be able to castle second
idea was to open up the e-file for his
rook and start creating threats against
the white king so something like d5 here
would be met with Knight f4 check and
the Bishop e2 Knight takes g2 with the
idea of King f1 Bishop d7 so just a
tactical point that if white takes the
knight black will be able to play check
and check in Queen g2 and black is going
to win the rook on h1 since rook F 1
would lose to Queen takes F 1 taking
advantage of this pin on the e-file so
white here played f3
and now comes a real shocker Bishop
takes f3 so once again black is willing
to sacrifice in order to prevent white
from finishing his development
okay White's idea was to block this
bishop from the G to pawn so that he
could play Bishop e2 and Castle but
because Farah was not allowing his
opponent to do that and thus the
sacrifice so Queen f3 would lose
immediately 295 check which is a simple
tactic but what happens after GTA except
3 now Queen h4 check and White has to
play rook f2 now Knight takes d4 check
Bishop e2 9 f3 check taking advantage of
both of these pins so why does the play
king f1 Queen h3 check in rook g2 and
now because for our play Knight h4 which
was actually not the best move the best
move here was rook a d8 which actually
almost won the game immediately but
before we go into that I just want to
mention that even if you didn't see
either of these moves Knight h4 or rook
88 and I'm not sure exactly how much
Kasparov calculated or how deeply he
calculated into the sacrifice but even
if you're not an amazing tactical genius
like Kasparov and you only were able to
see up to this point in your
calculations and you're trying to
evaluate whether this position would be
good for you I think it wouldn't be too
difficult to realize that black must
have great attacking potential here in
return for his sacrificed piece and the
reason is that this rook is pinned this
rook can only come to g1 where it's
still going to be passive and the
device pieces also aren't doing much
right meanwhile all of blacks pieces are
participating in the attack the queen is
very active the rook is delivering
enormous pressure on the e-file this
rook is about to come into d8 and be
very active as well and the night is
dominating all of White's pieces by
controlling all of these squares so with
that in mind it's not too far a stretch
of the imagination to realize that black
is going to be able to create very
powerful threats against whites
completely exposed King and the last
thing I want to mention here is that
blacks King is completely safe right
because he has these two extra pawns for
his piece and that's something that I
think a lot of players might forget
about is that okay you are down material
but the difference in King safety here
is very large and the difference in
piece activity is also important which
means that black here should have enough
tactical resources so that you can
justify going for the sacrifice even if
you haven't calculated all the way
through and now Rick 88 was a very
strong move and this move wins
tactically after something like Queen c2
black can play Knight d2 check and if
King f2 he has rookie 292 Queen f3
now if the King goes to g1 we have Queen
f1 mate and after King e1 we can just
take the rook on g2 and then black will
left two extra pawns and his attack will
continue another move I could try here
is 95 but now we play Knight h4 rook g1
and Queen f5 check and again we went
back our piece we have two extra pawns
and blacks attack would be just as
strong
ever but okay the move Kasparov play
nine h4 was also strong Brooke g1 and
now he played rook a d8 is bringing his
last piece into the attack and
increasing the pressure and the
difference here is that White has this
move Queen e1 which he didn't have with
the knight still on f3 but okay black
here still doing very well and he played
rook d3 very strong move just getting
ready to put the rook on e3 and increase
the pressure along the e file what's
important to realize here is that white
is almost completely paralyzed this rook
cannot move the King has nowhere to go
and this rook can't move the bishop is
pinned and the knight really doesn't
have anywhere to go
so Queen f2 and now Knight f3 and here
we really see how strong this attack is
because even the Queen here is paralyzed
it has no good moves if Queen g3 just 92
Czech and black wins the Queen this
Bishop cannot take the rook because of
Knight H to mate
so this Bishop again can't move the
Queen has no squares and if this Knight
moves black can win by rook d1 check
strip takes and Knight H to mate so
White's king is being trapped by his own
pieces all of which can't move which
means that black is doing very well here
so why it has nothing to do other than
rook H 1 now rook III and this Bishop
again can't move because of rook e1
check after which black will win a lot
of material so rook goes to g1 and since
black goes all the time in the world
you just place King h8 right very simple
move just getting out of any potential
tactics here with the g7 pawn if his
Queen was to ever move
doesn't really matter since white can't
move any of its pieces and you just go
through each one and now the final move
of the game b5 all of black's pieces are
performing optimally and Kasparov brings
in this last pawn to deliver the final
blow and the point is that he just wants
to play b4 attacking the knight which is
tied to the defense of the bishop the
only move I can really play here is a
three but after a5 the thread is renewed
so Rick g1 b4 and after the knight moves
black wins back is material has two
extra pawns and the attack continues so
after b5 mugga Rama of resigned and this
went down is one of co sparrows most
famous games and what I really like
about it is how logically all the moves
progressed in this entire game was just
a series of strong moves which maintain
the initiative for black and never gave
white a chance to breathe which is what
makes this game really instructive and a
great example of fantastic attacking
chess thanks a lot for listening and
I'll see you around on chess calm